las máquinas quitanieves están luchando
para despejar las carreteras y
autopistas desde Arizona hasta Wyoming
en Dakota del Sur El jefe del
Departamento de Obras Públicas de Six
Falls ha declarado que sus equipos
trabajan sin descanso para hacer frente
a la tormenta invernal
nuestros operadores de barrido han
estado fuera desde ayer están de vuelta
en sus turnos de 12 horas Así que vamos
a correr turnos de 24 horas hasta que lo
logremos Es probable que trabajen hasta
el domingo y potencialmente hasta la
próxima semana en estos turnos de 12
horas las condiciones en las carreteras
interestatales del país son malas con
vías heladas y con visibilidad casi nula
esta cámara capta el momento en que un
tractor remolque pierde el control y
derrapa en Wyoming funcionarios de todo
el medio oeste instaron a la gente a
permanecer fuera de las carreteras
consejo acogido por algunos camioneros
en Wisconsin mientras cenábamos las
carreteras empeoraban y empeoraban y
empeoraban y comentamos sabes que no
merece la pena Así que dijimos vamos
vamos a quedarnos Aquí esta noche y
estará salvo
la enorme tormenta ha provocado el
cierre de escuelas y la interrupción de
los viajes causando cientos de
cancelaciones y retrasos de vuelos y ha
dejado sin electricidad a más de 800.000
casas y empresas en cinco estados el
tiempo salvaje incluso ha traído
chubascos a las zonas desérticas fuera
de Los Ángeles algo que está encantando
a los residentes
hace un frío muy fuerte No estoy
acostumbrada a ver nieve en el desierto
pero es emocionante el hecho de que esté
nevando estoy muy muy emocionada soy
como una niña de 33 años estoy súper
emocionada Mientras tanto Al otro lado
del país se preparan para temperaturas
inusualmente altas a lo largo de la
costa este Se podrían alcanzar hasta 40
grados por encima de lo normal se espera
que en Washington DC se alcancen los 26
grados centígrados una máxima no vista
desde 1874